live from Washington DC hello everyone
i'm dana perino along with kimberly
guilfoyle juan williams Jesse Watters
and Greg Gutfeld five o'clock in our
nation's capital and this is the five
[Music]
[Laughter]
Capitol Hill the Student Union address
live at 9:00 p.m. Eastern the bells are
ringing it's amazing Gutfeld singing it
will be President Trump's first though
he did address a joint session of
Congress last February soon after his
inauguration we're expecting to get
excerpts soon we'll bring those to you
when they come in the White House says
the tone of the speech will be bright
and optimistic the president will seek
bipartisanship on a number of issues
jobs and the economy infrastructure
immigration trade and national security
it's been a contentious year between
Republicans and Democrats will there be
more compromise ahead more unity and
less divisive this let's go to the one
who is so optimistic bright and sunny
Greg what do you think oh my gosh - two
observations I think he's gonna support
he's going to do a great job because the
expectations are set so low by the media
they they are so upset with him and they
expect so little from him that all he
will have to do is just be expectations
are high for him this time oh I don't
think so at all I think that people
people are looking forward to him being
being evil and wrong and he'll be nice
but my other thing is I want to take a
page out of Andy Ferguson from the
Weekly Standard and Kevin Williamson
from Nats review it would be much better
if he got up there and he said you know
what you don't need this I tweet every
day you don't need the State of the
Union all you got to do is follow me on
Twitter I tell you everything that's on
my mind this is the first and last State
of the Union I'm ever gonna do take your
family out to dinner on those bonuses
I'm going home that would be the most
awesome State of the Union of all time
he might get a standing ovation he would
but that's the problem with this stuff
it's so fake the reason why the state of
the union sucks is that it's so fake
people standing up people sitting down
it's just it's so choreographed
manufactured it makes me sad inside like
a lot of things well one thing that is
clear from my look at this five-shot is
I am like one of the shortest people
ever you're just realizing that right
now may be a choice between a pillow or
a heated seat and I went with the heated
seat yeah I'm gonna steal that he did
see at the moment I'm a little here in
the hot seat all right what do you think
are you excited for tonight like like
Greg is
I am excited I don't want them to tweet
it because I want to watch Ruth Bader
Ginsburg fall asleep - she's not gonna
be there alt Arnott
okay well someone's gonna fall asleep
and someone will embarrass themselves at
one point the camera will go to a very
old senator and that senator will be
dozing off and those are the best
moments I'm also interesting to see who
people bring it turns out the Democrats
are bringing illegal aliens a lot of
people are saying they should bring ice
agents to just round them up right there
other people are bringing transgender
military members and I'm hearing the
Congressional Black Caucus might do a
black power fist and walk out so you
know all of these may be noble causes
but I really don't think the Democrats
are connecting with mainstream Americans
the president's going to be on
teleprompter and a lot of people that
support President Trumbull love
teleprompter Trump used to make fun of
Barack Obama when he was on the
teleprompter but we love President Trump
when he's on the teleprompter because he
sicced his script it's gonna be a lot of
recounting all the winning which could
take a very long time Juan especially
with all the applause and then he's
going to be the next year and try to
bring unity and find some items like
infrastructure immigration and trade
that the Democrats might be able to get
on board with find that one oh you know
I'm just overwhelmed by the winning it's
just been so much winning so when I look
into numbers I think oh my god this one
I said you'd be sick of it you want to
know because it's just so overwhelming I
am thrilled Jesse because I understand
as his guest he'll have liked stormy
Daniels maybe how about Steve we got
cheap shiny shiny Nowinski it was
$130,000 shot I think yeah I think what
you got here has killer how much it all
costs
Dana is a guy who is going to try to
stay on prompter to pick up on what
jesse was talking about and I think from
what we hear a Gary Cohen who did so
well for the president in Davos is
really in charge of this speech along
with Stephen milliner Stephen Miller is
kind of a fire-and-brimstone guy and I
think they're gonna try to bring a
little bit of that you look at the guest
list and you're gonna have people there
whose children were killed by ms-13 I
think they're gonna go back hard on the
immigration side of it and that's going
to come from Miller but I think from
Cohn you'll hear a lot of talk about the
benefits of economics
and the tax cut and the hope that while
he talks about America first he's not
saying this is I'm just repeating lines
that he said at Davos there's not
America alone and so in that sense it
really does speak to something I hope he
does which is reach out to the American
people and say that there is a
possibility but my fear is that's not
Donald Trump that so I'm just you know I
can't even a year ago in February when
he did the joint session speech
Kimberly it was a teleprompter speech
and remember that was where many
commentators from both the left and the
right said now that's a presidential
speech absolutely I think President
Trump is going to exceed expectations
tonight he has a lot of material to work
with in terms of the accomplishments
with the economy infrastructure tax
reform immigration all of the above so I
think there's a lot of check points that
he can make in terms of saying hey this
is what I promised the American people
the working-class men and women across
this country that felt forgotten I'm
honoring my promises that I made during
the campaign fulfilling them during my
presidency and the whole theme of a safe
and strong America is one that resonates
there can't be anybody who's against a
safe and strong prosperous country and
that's what he's going to hit tonight
one of the things that an economy a good
economy allows you to do Gregg is to
have some space to think about other
things that you want to work on so if
you if jobs are back and the American
people feel like the economy is better
they have confidence and you can deal
with other things so he's expected to
talk tonight about infrastructure and
opiate addiction in addition to
immigration I don't want him to talk
about anything
III have to reiterate this that I don't
want to hear what he can make government
do more of you should just do a little
punch list here's the jobs numbers
here's the economy here's how many Isis
fighters we killed okay that's what
happened this year I'm gonna try and do
some other things this year another
little punch list like three little
things and then just be done with it
this is not this is for the rest of
America
not for the left of America he shouldn't
care about impressing people that want
more government he should just do it you
know what he is the reason why he's so
different and the reason why everybody
has problems with him it is that he's
running a country like it's a business
he's like a boss and he can't shake it
so he should just treat it like a
meeting with a
Lincoln comes in there goes okay so we
did this we did this we did this that's
all right we got to do this and if we
don't do this you're in trouble I'm
firing this guy that's how he talks he
should just do that because the way it
used to go before let's face it didn't
matter who was doing the State of the
Union it was pompous and choreographed
and we pretended to be interested let's
just let it go but you're definitely
gonna watch yes I have to but you know
what it is it's like the great thing
about Trump is he like look at the
Correspondents Dinner those things all
these traditional things implode under
his watch why can't this one gonna be
the last as well so you'd like it to be
but the President does receive better
numbers when he does these big historic
events you get the pomp and circumstance
the majesty of it all Trump does very
well the Democrats on the other hand
have I think six different responses to
the State of the Union so they're
totally fractured and who knows what
they're going to say Bernie's doing his
thing
I believe Kamala Harris is doing her
thing who knows what the Democratic
Party stands for anymore so I think
Trump will receive a big bump after
tonight that was a headline today one
that said I'm the Democrats especially
in red states are starting to panic
because of all the good economic news I
don't think that's rational because one
of the interesting things about Trump's
poor poll numbers is that if you ask the
American people about the economy they
say if the economy is good economic
confidence consumer confidence up but
they don't necessarily connect that to
Donald Trump they give lots of credit
fact they get more credit to Barack
Obama a true and obviously most
presidents while they're in office they
take credit for anything because they
also get blamed for everything but
here's a situation where the American
people say clearly the recovery was
ongoing Trump comes in I think by the
way in response to Greg's terrible
attitude about our wonderful State of
the Union address you get you get you're
gonna have some reality TV and you have
got mr. reality TV delivering oh no this
movie so I think you're gonna have
people who don't show up I think lots of
members of the Hispanic Caucus the Black
Caucus just said hey watch that show up
and listen to a guy yeah
because we called Trump out on the lies
I do think Kimberly there every one of
the thing one of the reasons that Greg
and others feel that way about the State
of the Union is because it is it was
never supposed to be that way the state
of the union is supposed to be just a
letter really or just a notification
that everything's fine don't worry about
stuff but it has grown so much but the
visualization of who you bring it's
almost become more important than the
actual words of the speech and tonight
both sides are going to have very
compelling and interesting members of
the American public there yeah it's also
a visual presentation in terms of who's
who who you can get for your side to
sort of be symbolic in terms of your
party your movement the type of things
that you want to accomplish and also
maybe some of the points that you want
to make that you need to improve upon
you say okay I have the support from
this community or that community but I
do think that President Trump besides
having a you know visual presentation of
who shows up for him is also really
gonna be strong in terms of the rhetoric
and mirroring some of the themes that he
laid out in Davos as well because he
does have quite a bit to work with and
for president Trump I don't think he's
going to you know miss the opportunity
to capture the moment for the American
people because there's a lot more that
he wants to accomplish and this is the
way and the vehicle by which that he can
really grow into that support moving
forward for some of the legislative
policies and things that he'd like to
accomplish Jessie you last word for all
the Democrats that say this guy is the
worst president of all time they're
gonna be jumping over themselves to try
to shake his hand as he walks down the
aisle to get a nice photo opportunity so
they could send the back so they could
you miss the idea that people aren't
showing up to protests that would be
black so Chum shake any democratic as
you want that one no I'd say gonna make
some people I'm saying the news is it's
like you know they say it's not news
about the Jets that land at national
airports it's news about the Jets the
crash and then I realize no one cares
there's lot so I'm not only not showing
up it's their protest in the street